SCP-682 Vs SCP-162.
The Hard to Destroy reptile was brought in
front of the nightmarish contraption known
as the “Ball of Sharp”, a malevolent ball
of sharp objects that draws its victims in
and tears them apart.
682 screamed profanities
as it was brought before the ball.
It then extended its deadly hooks, tearing
off one of 682’s forelimbs and its bottom
jaw after a violent struggle.
That’s when 682 broke containment, dragging
162 along with it and using it to slaughter
eleven different members of personnel, as
well as injuring nearly 90 others.
Two additional deaths were caused during the
recovery, and the researchers who had organized
the cross-test were all given a disciplinary.